now the latest on the efforts to prevent
a potentially disastrous government
default President Biden invited
Congressional leaders to the White House
yesterday to talk about raising the debt
ceiling the only thing they agreed on
was to have another meeting at O'Keefe
is at the White House with more on that
Ed I understand both sides were unhappy
when they walked out of that room
yesterday that's one way of putting it
Gail good to see you President Biden and
Congressional leaders are no closer to a
deal and if anything they're doubling
down on their dueling positions with a
June 1st default deadline hanging over
Washington all the leaders signaling
they'd like to remove the threat of
default but house Speaker Kevin McCarthy
said he didn't see any new movement
towards an agreement that said the
president and Congressional leaders are
instructing staff to keep working on
details and as Gayle said they plan to
meet again on Friday keep an eye today
however on the president as he travels
to New York's Hudson Valley and a house
District representative by a republican
that he won in 2020. the president's
goal is to pressure moderate Republicans
to break with the GOP and come up with a
bike partisan solution little politics
being played Vlad while the policy War
continues and just a little over a week
to go at a couple of days left for
Congress to work I thank you very much